we saw capitulation there's just no
doubt about that where like you can go
through like you know all these
statistics average cost basis whatever
you know the average Bitcoin holder was
underwater
um you know in the fall of 2022. that
happens cyclically every single Bitcoin
bear Market in the same way that you
know the say the average cost basis the
Bitcoin exchange rate is usually like
three four x the average cost basis at
the top these kind of local bubbles
crashes everyone on average uh is
underwater that happened again right so
we saw a massive capitulation like we
can see it in the data
all right guys bang bang I've got Dylan
here with me uh you've been on a tear my
friend although I can't see your tweets
all the time because I think they're
suppressing you somehow uh you've been
firing for like six months straight I
don't know what happened contagion macro
issues uh nonsense in the Bitcoin
markets but nonsense in the crypto
markets when you look back over the last
six months or so we'll go back pre FTX
and and kind of the second wave if you
will of all the failures in the industry
yeah how do you think about what's
transpired like how do you describe
what's happened yeah it was uh I mean it
was the biggest absolute contagion event
in in the big the history of Bitcoin
crypto broadly
um it was like bitcoin's first kind of
native financial crisis uh with no
lender of Last Resort so that was like
certainly an interesting uh phenomenon
to observe as a participant and just
kind of a an outside Observer of a lot
of these different exchanges and uh you
know the broad ecosystem uh there was
kind of a convergence between Bitcoin
and macro for all 2022 and then there
was the you know kind of a decoupling
but unlike what people suspected it was
a decoupling to the downside
um and so yeah I mean I think we flushed
we flushed everything out for the most
part
um certainly could like you know the
exchange rate of Bitcoin go lower like I
still think we actually get a recession
and it's probably what surprised me is
that uh I I thought it was gonna happen
sooner I thought you know we had this
big Global bust and asset prices uh
fastest tightening cycle in history
um the base case was that we were going
to get a recession and it still is but I
um maybe naively thought it would happen
a little bit sooner and I think are we
in a recession uh I think according to
the the the numbers you know official
government numbers I don't think we are
um the economy is actually still pretty
hot in nominal terms you have kind of
like a two-tiered economy it's like you
have the interest rate financialized
economy so you know Wall Street VC you
know Tech like we're in kind of like a
white collar recession of sorts
um and then there's like kind of like
the blue collar uh service sector which
is still still like pretty pipe and hot
right I mean you know Miami's busting uh
bustling busting
I'll throw data at you ready so the
inflation rate in Miami is 10 yeah wow
right crazy uh Miami now has the
wealthiest neighborhoods like two of the
top five neighborhoods in the entire
country uh because home prices have
exploded higher uh on top of that uh I
was reading an article today on
Bloomberg where they basically were like
it is Jerome Powell in the FED versus
the service industry that is going to
determine uh the inflation battle and at
the same time that they're raising
interest rates and they're you know
destroying investment demand and kind of
this white collar stuff right uh the
service industry is increasing pay
they're increasing prices and they
basically are saying to themselves if we
don't increase our labor costs and also
increase our product cost we're not
going to survive yeah and so he's got to
do a lot more to go after that industry
but the people caught in the crosshairs
or the white collar kind of investment
class and and I mean some of these
stocks are down 60 70 percent let alone
you know Bitcoin crypto whatever yeah
it's it's nasty out there yeah it's
really interesting like this business
cycle is is a lot different than you
know um maybe the historical analogies
of the past like some people are like oh
it's like oh wait some people are like
oh it's like kind of similar to the tech
bubble right where you had all these
crazy valuations and then they they bust
um and I guess if you just think back to
the tech bubble right like everybody
thinks about the NASDAQ going down 80
what people don't really think about is
two and a half years later in 2002 the S
P 500 was 50 from its highs right so
like these things do take time um I
think that two-tiered economy thing is
is very very true
um and you know I guess like if you
going back say like 2021 if you said you
know the fed's gonna get rates to five
and some change percentage uh and things
are going to be able to you know sustain
for a while I would have been surprised
that would have caught me off guard um
and since then I'm obviously I've kind
of realigned the expectations uh but I
still think that the end game as in kind
of this broad thesis this big debt uh
debts long-term debt cycle thesis is is
uh accurate still in play like there's
just mathematically not there's not a
way we can serve it not like not just
the US government not just the treasury
but like globally debt burdens are still
so high and only the only really way out
is to kind of let this inflation run hot
first sustained period of time so it's
interesting right they laid out the
Playbook they're like all right we need
to devalue this debt we're going to let
inflation run hot if you look at what
they said in 2020 they're like we need
inflation hot inflation came hot right
got hotter and hotter and I don't think
what what they missed or not maybe what
they missed but what they didn't
perceive was the social and political
pressure that would come as a result of
that not just the us but globally right
just like first inflation crisis in 40
50 years right so there's a lot of
political pushback and so you know they
instead of they were still doing QE and
and zero interest rate policy a year ago
right like people I mean it doesn't feel
like that but I mean they were literally
pumping 100 billion dollars a month into
the into financial sector 12 months ago
so we're still pretty early in this
cycle and it's going to be interesting
to see how it plays out
um but I still think we're we're due for
some form of broad economic downturn how
do you think Bitcoin would perform as we
get deeper into kind of a recessionary
period right there's a lot of people who
said hey bitcoin's never lived through a
recession before if you look over the
last 18 months or so obviously we've
raised interest rates
um and had that tightening cycle Bitcoin
went down along with all other Financial
assets but many people would argue like
actually it's holding in there okay now
right for the last you know call it six
months or whatever it's been uh it's
pretty much flat yep and is your
expectation that we've kind of bottomed
in this whole down cycle could a
recession push us lower like how do you
think Bitcoin performs yeah I mean I
like to view everything like
probabilistically
um you know a lot of the data we look at
like the on-chain Bitcoin native kind of
stuff like we saw capitulation there's
just no doubt about that where like you
can go through like you know all these
statistics average cost basis whatever
you know the average Bitcoin holder was
underwater
um you know in the fall of 20 22. that
happens cyclically every single Bitcoin
bear Market in the same way that you
know the say the average cost basis the
Bitcoin exchange rate is usually like
three four x the average cost basis at
the top these kind of local bubbles it
crashes everyone on average uh is
underwater that happened again right so
we saw a massive capitulation like we
can see it in the data
um there was some form of seller
exhaustion right like I mean every
lender exchange hedge fund Market maker
in the space you know the titans of the
industry in 2020 2021 basically all blew
up right
um you know gbtc holding 600 000 Bitcoin
trading at a 50 discount to it and that
asset value like like that you know with
that yeah is that bad yeah if that's not
capitulation then I don't really know
what is um but I think people kind of
mistake that okay we saw capitulation we
saw you know as worse as it you know
probably gets versus okay and now we're
in for just like a sustained period of
some chop consolidation like I think
people are like okay the worst is over
time for up only
um and I think Bitcoin as a macro asset
um it I mean it has matured over the
last three four years despite you know
the volatility to the upside and the
downside I think it is it is more of a
macro asset than it was in 2018 2019.
um so you know what are equities doing
today uh well that's probably what
bitcoin's doing with maybe a little bit
more volatility and so I think we got
some time like I I you know I would be
very surprised to see Bitcoin I happily
I would be you know happily surprised if
Bitcoin made new all-time highs in 23
but I have plenty of time we have time
right like the the broad thesis of
Bitcoin as an engineering solution a
superior engineering implementation uh
for money is is completely unchanged
right I think it's just a timeline and
the narratives uh got people a little
bit caught off sides right like Bitcoin
is inflation hedge and it's like well
CPI inflation comes in we see the first
kind of bond stock market correlation to
the downside in 50 years and and not
just like Bitcoin crypto investors but
like Legacy investors right who are like
okay we're you know stocks are falling
we're going to Long bonds and they got
absolutely pillaged right so like
Bitcoin on a risk adjusted basis
actually didn't even do that bad in 22.
right like bonds traded worse a lot of
equities traded worse
um and risk adjusted in 23 Bitcoins like
one of the best performers so you know I
think the game is unchanged it's just
it's a game of accumulation and patience
yeah
um when you think about the decoupling
that's occurred at the start of 2023
explain what's happening there and like
how you think about that
uh well I mean I don't really think
there has like I mean maybe like locally
like a day or two right
um you know decent short squeeze in
Bitcoin but like you saw kind of a rip
in a lot of these kind of um beaten up
names right whether it's like the Teslas
of the world or Tech uh or equities
broadly um we kind of just on like a
general risk on rally
um there was why do you think that's
happening that is like I'm trying to
front run the Fed pivot or something
else yeah I think there's a belief um
that I think is reversing uh that okay
we're gonna see that I think the
consensus in in Q4 of 22 was okay
um we got this tightening cycle things
are really slowing down
um the inflation is actually you know uh
transitory uh we're gonna return to this
kind of this neem two percent uh year
over year line uh and the fed's gonna
cut in in 23. you saw like you know fed
futures
um the bond market really kind of expect
that okay we're gonna go from four or
five percent rates down to three we're
gonna ease stocks kind of front ran that
um bonds we're pricing in a recession
inequities are pricing in like this
Goldilocks scenario of no earnings
recession and you know future cuts and
now all of those cuts that were expected
in 23 you know three four rate cuts um
that's all kind of been priced back out
so no Cuts in 23
um economy is still really nominally hot
uh and I think now 2024 is is when
broadly the consensus is starting to
price in that that real slowdown so
earnings recession
um you know the feds openly stating we
want slack in the labor market you know
that is a translation for we want some
of you guys to get fired from from your
jobs like this is what they want to do
they want to destroy demand and so
um you know what's interesting is the
dichotomy we kind of talked about like
five minutes ago between the white
collar kind of uh you know Wall Street
VC Tech uh you know interest rate
sensitive parts of the economy versus
like the service industry anybody that's
receiving social benefits from the from
the government right like anyone that's
that's getting Social Security just got
an eight nine percent pay raise right so
in real terms like they didn't really
get a pay raise but in nominal terms
they they feel pretty good they feel you
know they got money to spend
um there's still like one 1.5 trillion
dollars of like excess savings from all
the coveted stimulus that hasn't been
run through
um so there's like you know the consumer
despite you know the savings rate being
low the consumer still has a good amount
of cash to Chuck around so the economy
is is you know if you asked me six
months ago 2023 we're going to see no
recession I would have been very very
surprised but I think the data is
showing that you know the us at least is
in a pretty decent spot and so that
gives the FED some uh some room so I
mean to be honest I wouldn't even be
surprised to see six percent rates on
the FED funds
um but if you told me that in 2020 I
would have said no way you know so so I
mean that's that's certainly something
that's evolved what is interesting is uh
things like
um service worker pay continues to be
very strong and increasing a lot of
these like local small businesses
increasing prices
um we see kind of this white collar
recession that you're describing but we
look at the American Consumer uh you
have a savings rate that has been
absolutely destroyed it's at a historic
low credit card debt exploding upwards
interest rate on that credit card debt
exploding upwards um and it's like all
the signs that like the consumers in
trouble and at the same time that we're
like on the precipice of a recession and
the consumer is struggling the FED is
basically like kind of walking over to
the cliff and they're like I'm gonna
kick these people people off right and
like let's see what happens
um
do you think that they have to just
focus on inflation and like whatever
pain comes to the consumer uh we just
got to deal with it or like can there be
that soft Landing that they keep kind of
pointing to saying like you know we'll
we'll put the ship right into the Hudson
uh like uh pilot Sully over there and
like we'll be good we'll all walk out of
this thing yeah I think uh you know
there was there was increasing belief uh
in late Q4 early q1 you know January
time frame where where it was like okay
we're gonna go from everyone kind of
thought there's a hard Landing coming to
soft Landing to no Landing right like oh
this all of a sudden they might they
might actually do this
um and I think with with kind of you see
like China opening up their you know
shoving money out again they're printing
um you know the consumer's still pretty
strong like you're talking about the
service industry that's still piping hot
um inflation which is you know part of
their dual mandate we could debate you
know I think that's a different story
about like whether that mandate is even
uh
not worthy but you know they're they're
kind of their dual mandated of maximum
unemployment and two percent inflation
uh or you know what what's the official
wording of that price stability right
it's not I mean price increasing uh
isn't stability but that's another story
um I mean we can have that debate about
whether that's even the right goal to
have um
um I think it's a it's you know part of
this Keynesian economic Paradigm which
is you know everybody's kind of
um been raised in and brought up in um
and so like the Bitcoin perspective the
Austrian perspective kind of looks
outside of that box
um almost like you know from like a a
fourth dimension it's like we're looking
in on this in this system this incumbent
system like you know this is this is the
Matrix
um but this is the world we're in right
I'm not naive like I'm not naive enough
to to to not understand the game that's
being played right so the feds you know
the FED despite you know the Labor uh
Force participation dropping after kovid
right this official data says
unemployment's at 50 or lows right so uh
3.4 3.4 numbers yeah uh and the small
business down the street can't find
anyone to work yeah
um and so it's certainly a really
interesting business cycle
um and I think they're going to uh
they're going to really and who knows
maybe they don't follow through maybe uh
you know Powell kind of uh or as uh
their Burns reincarnated you know the
Fed chair that in the face of inflation
kind of backed off and let it rip right
um that would certainly be uh very very
interesting but I think um and this is
political right I think they were
embarrassed by the transitory column 21.
um you know inflation transitory don't
worry guys they were dead wrong and um
because of that their credibility uh was
was kind of shot a little bit so they're
going to I think they're going to try to
reinforce that their dominance I guess
uh on the market and I think they they
purposefully want to inflict pain so you
know Financial assets
um I you know some people are pretty
bullish for 23 I I think stocks and
bonds continue to be correlated I think
they struggle
um I think Bitcoin could have periods of
decoupling or relative strength but I I
don't suspect a Raging Bull Market
um at least for the time being
um you know so Bitcoin if we look at the
on-chain metrics I think it's 73 or so
of all Bitcoin in circulation hasn't
moved uh in over a year or somewhere
around there whatever the date is uh or
data is today
um that would say that we have a highly
illiquid Market uh but in order to get
that Raging Bull Market you need some
sort of catalyst when you look out over
the next couple of years uh some people
may point to the having Others May point
to other things what do you think could
be a catalyst to kind of set off the
next you know true bull market and kind
of not just sideways or or the stoppage
of going down but actually to go back up
hey guys what's going on I hope that
you're enjoying this conversation I
wanted to interrupt for a second to tell
you about an event that we're hosting on
March 4th at the Miami Beach Convention
Center it's called lyceum Miami and I've
gone and asked some of the most popular
guests from this show over the years to
come in person at the event it's gonna
be awesome we have everyone from Kathy
Wood to Vivek Mama Swami Chris
Williamson Cody Sanchez and many many
others I
even have a couple of surprises for each
one of you if you show up the best part
about this event is it is completely
free to attend that's right all general
admission tickets are free you simply
need to go to
lyceummiami.com
lyceummiami.com will get you free
tickets on March 4th at the Miami Beach
Convention Center and if you're a big
baller and don't just want to get a free
ticket you can also get it VIP or an
Insider pass if you use the code pop 40
you'll get 40 off they get you all kinds
of cool things like the night before a
cocktail with the actual speakers and a
couple other perks go check it all out
at lyceum miami.com and use code pump 40
if you want to be a baller I can't wait
to see all of you there go ahead and
click on the link in the description and
let's get back into this conversation
yeah it's pretty interesting because
like you know we were we were talking
throughout 2021 2022 one of the things
that that surprised me during the second
leg of the kind of the double bubble in
2021 you know Bitcoin hidden all time is
64 000 crashed to 30 000 after the China
thing
um and you know like Elon kind of double
bubble yeah and then we you know in
hindsight obviously FTX had something to
do with it you know there was a you know
some other Shenanigans the altcoin
ecosystem kind of helped inflate
re-inflate that
um but it was really interesting because
I'm looking at all this data right and
you know
um Bitcoin there was there was days
where Bitcoins up 10 stocks down bonds
down you know vix volatility up in
Legacy markets and it's like you know
what is going on at the same time we're
looking at this data and it's like holy
crap you know like
60 70 80 of the supply isn't moving
right like whoever's in this market
bidding this is having to fight for like
a super small uh part of this pie and so
that the the decoupling or like the at
least the theory of of a decoupling
looked very very real and I think in
hindsight what uh I got I got wrong at
least a little bit locally
um as as we drew down was does that
Supply can remain super super
constrained
um that supply and elasticity Cuts not
only up but it cuts down it cuts both
ways right so 80 of the supply doesn't
care they're press agnostic buyers
they're holders they don't they don't
give a crap about the exchange rate
um but that you know 20 or like even you
know the two million coins on exchanges
that trades every day right whether it's
market makers or hedge funds or you know
speculators uh walking trading yeah
because of of of that inelasticity not
only does it you know in a Raging Bull
Market is it a clear beneficiary but in
a bear market right that supply and
elasticity also leads to downside
volatility right so so I think that
that's apply being super super tightly
held and very very liquid
um is is fantastic for for a bull market
when there's marginal inflows
um but if there's you know any marginal
outflows or you know people are just
trading this like it's a derivative of
the S P 500 right that's applying
elasticity on a day-to-day basis doesn't
really that it doesn't matter right and
and on the margin if you have people
that are continuing to acquire it and
buy it and hold it and not sell it um
that's going to make a difference
um but I think you know the the next
like it's really you need that you need
that that kick you need that that spark
what do you think it could be
um I I think I mean the obvious one is
like you know monetary easing like you
know we have a recession there's some
form of fiscal and uh monetary response
um but I think you know eventually it
could just be like at least the last
couple months it's been somewhat of like
a salary exhaustion short squeeze right
it's just like Supply set at the margin
for any asset this is an absolutely
scarce one it's tightly held there's
just not enough coins to go around
um I mean to to kick it back to a
trillion dollar asset class is going to
take you know a little bit more inflows
than we have currently but I think you
know and uh we see the SEC coming down a
little bit I think in like as much as
I'm uh I kind of have uh the the and cap
side of me that the libertarian free
market maximalist side of me uh I
understand the world we live in I
understand that you know the regulatory
environment is going to keep some
institutions
um you know that are bootstrapped by
this stuff on the sidelines at least at
least locally
um and I think one you know this stuff
gets cleared up a little bit I you know
who knows what they do with the stable
coins all this but I think you know we
got a little bit until some of that's
figured out and some of the big boys
um you know the public companies the big
institutions
um like bitcoin's very very illiquid
like we said and that's that's a good
thing but like if you were of
institution say an insurance company
right and you want 50 base points you
want one percent of your portfolio in
Bitcoin because you're looking at it and
you're saying hey in the bear Market it
does well risk adjusted in a bull market
it does well risk adjusted let's get a
sliver of this thing and you have a you
know a 500 billion dollar portfolio as
an insurance fund and it's it's long
duration right you have you have payouts
for the next 40 years
um I mean
try deploying a billion dollars into the
Bitcoin market like you're gonna send
the price up right and likewise if you
had a billion dollars to sell
um the e-liquidity is going to cut the
other way and so like you can see like
it's kind of fun you can see whenever
sailor over the past years like on the
tape it's like oh there's a coinbase
buyer and it's just like you see in the
data like there's someone just chipping
away buying every second like so I think
you know it's still very varied despite
being 13 14 years old
um the good news or maybe bad depending
on how you perceive it but the good news
is it's still very immature still very
early and it's still very nascent
um that it is a globally liquid asset
but it's not it's not nearly as liquid
as a lot of the Legacy assets so you
know the good news is it's early
um the the bad news is like you know the
big boys uh can't really come in because
of you know regulatory because of public
perception you know people say oh
Bitcoin but like they perceive it as
like crypto FTX fraud you know I can't
touch that thing
um so you know I think obviously
education is important these are
long-term things and if that's you know
that's the the battle we're facing when
you think of Regulation is their uh
potential oversight of stable coins the
most surprising
piece of what's transpired over the last
couple of months like obviously there's
things around three Euros Capital around
Terra Luna around FTX right like like
things that obviously had issues in the
last year or two
um but then something like stable coins
I think a lot of people look and they're
like
sure I thought maybe that they would go
after some of the coins or all of the
coins or whatever but stable coins never
really seem to be the thing that people
pointed to and was like I think
Regulators are going to have a problem
with that or they're going to think this
is you know outside of uh kind of the
the fence that they want this stuff in
is that the same way you read it
yeah it's
it's because you know I
I think that the dynamic has changed a
little bit now with this interest rate
environment right stable coins in a zero
interest rate policy world isn't the
most lucrative business right you're
just you know kind of tokenizing some
dollars some short duration treasuries
um and you know those compliance costs
and all this other stuff if you want to
operate in the US obviously there's the
tethers of the world and and whatnot but
uh with with short end rates at five
percent
I mean having a multi-billion dollar
stable coin is a profit puppy right
um you know coinbase is like just
reported their revenue I I forget what
the numbers were but a lot of their
revenue is just from their Circle
program they just they just have a bunch
of cash and their users have cash on the
platform they don't pay them interest
and they just they just get that that
short-term uh interest rate
um you know tether now is this reporting
like a bunch of profits because they
have a ton of their their cash and
liquid treasuries
um so from the regulation perspective
um it's it's clear that uh stable coins
is a very lucrative business and I think
you know the next five you know this may
be this decade you're going to see a lot
of the Legacy incumbent players want a
piece of the pie right like you see
Circle teaming up with BlackRock you
know uh not only like are stable coins
uh a path to monetize treasuries for the
US government right uh it's a structural
buyer of of of U.S debt
um and that's a good thing they want
that you know they want more buyers like
if you just look at the past 30 40 years
it's always the the government's always
trying to figure out okay who's gonna be
the buyer our dead you know the Saudis
Russia China right and you know and the
FED obviously and a lot of those
sovereigns have kind of stepped back a
little bit stable coins like it's 100
billion dollar market today it could
very easily be a trillion dollar market
tomorrow or not tomorrow but you know
the next few years
um and so that's a big Market
opportunity not only for like the US
government and to find structural buyers
of the debt but also for the Legacy
players who just get to tokenized
dollars or you know you know stable coin
on a blockchain and then get that
interest expense so I think there's
there's kind of that regulatory pressure
is partially because there is a lot of
interest to capture this business
um and it's a political game right it's
a regulatory game it's a political game
uh and and the crypto uh incumbents
despite you know being relatively in a
much better place than they were say in
2016 2017 2018 are you know still just
kind of drops in the bucket compared to
the the Legacy Titans what is your take
on uh uh Nostra I guess I pronounce it
yeah and ordinals
uh yeah no sir is really cool
um I'm on Noster I don't post much but
it's exciting and it's it's growing
unbelievably fast I mean at least I
don't know it is a decentralized uh
social site uh that basically allows you
to use public address
um and send messages uh via kind of
peer-to-peer relays
um uh very similar to bitcoin yeah so
it's yeah public private Keys um I think
that the the basics of the protocol have
existed for like two decades
um but it was just you know just kind of
this novel implementation of this
technology so uh kind of kind of similar
to bitcoin like the technology existed
for a while it was just someone kind of
like finally just like putting the
pieces together and introducing it a
different way
um it's very exciting it's like you know
you can send lightning uh you can like
zap people's SATs yeah it was just like
basically like you see Twitter is like
implementing Twitter coins I don't know
if you saw that
um but you know they probably are
spending all this money to implement
this like their own coin and this all
this program and meanwhile we have this
very very basic like if you look at the
Noster or the the Damas
um app on on uh the app store that's
just like an implementation of the noser
protocol they built it on top it's like
a ux
um it's like five megabytes it's tiny
right
um and so and use like relays to do it
so it's not the most user-friendly thing
like like my mom's not gonna sign up for
for Noster and as easy as Twitter
because if if I ask you right now like
hey what's your profile yeah you
basically are gonna tell me a Pub Key
yeah right um which you probably I'm
assuming don't have it memorized no and
so therefore uh it's not the same thing
as like hey follow me on Twitter at what
yeah right and so that's some of that
has to be fixed those necessarily mean
it's not gonna work it's just like uh it
has to get to the point where it's so
user friendly that you can get even more
mainstream adoption than people who are
willing to kind of Overlook the UI ux
stuff yeah and like I you know for the
for like three or I think two or three
months I saw Jack Dorsey posting about
it and he was you know back when there
was probably a couple hundred users he
was on that I I logged on created a
thing
um and he's on there you know five hours
a day and he's you know chucking Bitcoin
at developers and and you know setting
this stuff up in Africa and I'm like you
know Jack's pretty smart guy he's
created two massive companies uh founded
two you know Twitter and square
um very very very early to bitcoin and
then that implementation was square like
this guy knows what he's doing
um why is he so obsessed with this thing
and I think it's because Jack I mean
Jack was in the mid middle of the storm
with Twitter with the political pressure
and understands the reality of running a
you know a public forum social media
company
um you know we we don't even have to go
into all the stuff that happened in 2020
2021 the censorship I mean hell I lost
my my back when verification was like a
uh you know kind of a credentialism
thing I was like official journalist for
a media company in Bitcoin Magazine's a
verified media company I was you know a
journalist posted some coveted wrong
think I lost my verification and they
said you know you're I got an email
you're no longer notable uh and and it
was essentially like it was a warning
shot it was like Hey like and for me
like Twitter is like a pretty uh
important part of my career and what I
do and so it was like all right like it
was almost like I I self-censored
because like I don't want to get banned
off this site it's very integral to what
I do and you saw a lot of people look
prominent you know scientists whatever
that got banned so there's there's
problems with centralized social media
and I think the reason Jack's so
obsessive with Noster
um are not obsessive but passionate and
funding all this development
um is because the idea of a you know a
decentralized identification system and
social network is very very powerful
another kind of rabbit hole is like deep
fakes and artificial intelligence like
pomp both of us and you way more than
myself have hundreds thousands of hours
of of uh live video
out there for the internet
um I don't know if you've seen like the
The Joe Biden Donald Trump kind of deep
fakes where they're talking to each
other and saying saying funny stuff I
want someone to put me in the video game
with uh Biden Trump or Mike you can
throw somebody else in there and just
like two on two yeah and uh let us go at
it but like it's it's funny but it's
also a little scary [__] like I mean
this is relatively new technology I mean
I guess they've been building it behind
the scenes but extrapolate it out right
just like the general trend of
Technology where it's going in five
years from now it's probably gonna be
trivial to fake a video of yourself
saying something and whatever it may be
right it could be as malicious or or you
know fun as as you want to Envision
um but how what's like how do you verify
what's real and not in a world where
it's it's at it costs nothing to create
a fake of something right so and so and
we've we've we're already like we're not
screwed but you're you're 10 000 hours
of content's already there right maybe
you could try to scrub it all but you
can't you can't scrap yeah so so the the
decentralized identification as a
concept as like okay this is a public
private key verification system for me
and what I say and what I post right
like I think that's not even just with
no stir but in general you're gonna need
something
um like that to to verify publicly in
the future and so I don't know what that
word looks like um but you know that
Trend
um is really something that has caught
my attention recently what about
ordinals are you a nft Maximus now I
don't have any NFC Max Plus I think it's
interesting
um you know it's a very it's the the
surprising thing was that a lot of
extremely smart uh Bitcoin uh
technologists developers uh you know
like Luke Dasher Jr like creator of the
segwit implementation you know kind of
solution to the block War uh drama
conflict in 2017
um and a lot of the guys that coded up
Taproot didn't see this coming
um and then you know some of them were
even saying like you're you're cheating
the code right but I don't think that at
all I think it's a novel use of block
space
um this is a free market and if someone
wants to pay up to put a JPEG or
whatever on a blockchain then uh it's a
public it's a public marketplace right
and so a lot of people are saying this
solves the fee problem I never thought
there was a fee problem to begin with
these have been near all-time lows right
for quite a while yeah well I just think
that in you know the difficulty
adjustment
um and you know the the trend of Bitcoin
usage and adoption is going to I mean
just the nature of the big the the
difficulty adjustment and Mining
incentives there's going to be an
equilibrium for fees in the future if
there's no fees to pay up I mean people
will use Bitcoin to transact I think
that it's valuable enough it's already
won the censorship game
um and there's there's nothing else
immutable
um so people will pay to use Bitcoin if
there's not enough fees miners will stop
mining you know there's a queue of
transactions will clog in the mempool an
equilibrium will be found now there's an
additional driver for Block space demand
you know that changes the equilibrium
but it doesn't really change the
fundamental uh kind of truth of Bitcoin
as this you know uh open public thing
that anybody can utilize um so I think
it's cool um you know maybe I'll
mint and inscription or ordinal uh but
you know a lot of people are having fun
with it so what's interesting to me is
both of those uh seem to have brought a
lot of attention to uh to bitcoin
um I think that there's this one impact
of like there a whole new class of
bitcoiners showed up between like 2020
and 2022 right I think uh some of the
data was like uh half of all Bitcoin or
should have been 2021 right and so they
only knew really the economic
conversation around Bitcoin and now
there's multiple examples with both of
those and other things that are
happening where people get like
re-inspired and they're like oh this
could be you know uh um kind of this
really powerful technology this could be
used for a lot of different things
um and it's hard to measure what's going
on there but I think uh Nostra has 700
000 uh people have downloaded now or
something 700 000 users wow that's a big
number right whatever the 500k a million
whatever it is it's big number
um and then the ordinals I saw there's
tens of thousands I think that have been
created at this point and so like like
you look at that and you're like I don't
know very many companies that have
brought that many people to use their
products on bitcoin like that in a long
time and so it's pretty impressive to
see you know what they've been able to
do yeah
um I think it's cool that you know
there's there's a certain cohort of
people in crypto broadly that that not
like to hop from thing to thing but like
you know the crypto native class it's
like okay you know we're gonna mint and
a tease on Ethan then hop to Solana and
then do this on D5 and whatever and and
those people in in general for the
longest time have been like listen
bitcoin's cool it's the biggest thing
it's the most liquid thing it you know
uh kind of
takes the direction of the market either
way it's King but it's boring as hell
right and like I'll say this as a
Bitcoin or like Bitcoin
um I mean not its exchange Raider but
like if you're trying to report on what
Bitcoin does every day it's like okay
well you know
900 Bitcoin remind we found a bunch of
blocks right like you could write the
article the day before but yeah you can
just copy paste it every day it's like
oh Bitcoins
operating right like uh and you know
there's an occasional soft Fork that's
exciting but like fundamentally the
system is just does what it does and it
just continues and they're almost
recovering Twitter yeah conversation
more than you do the actual blockchain
yeah yeah
um and so it is interesting that there's
kind of a technological debate to it and
a new class of of investors excited to
utilize this thing I think that's really
exciting um so it's still very nascent
um you know I I'm not really like I mean
certainly like could these things
appreciate a whole bunch yeah um but you
know the the speculative art stuff uh
that doesn't interest me like that's I
think that does a disservice um because
it's a new novel thing but like you know
uh I'm I'm not so much of like a a
collector myself maybe that'll change
we'll see
all right I want to do rapid fire
questions to uh to end it here uh
Bitcoin hash rate hits new all-time high
uh in 2023 if there's a recession or
hash rate goes down
yeah hash rate just keeps chugging I
mean it's at all-time highs right now
300X Hash a second
um I think it's a bunch of Asics on the
sidelines
um waiting like you know if price takes
up at all you're gonna see uh more more
of that come online I think this is
there's a structural shortage of
Rackspace uh after all these mining
blobs core scientific Celsius all this
um you know they're all miners
um and so this this stuff takes time but
yeah I mean it's certainly mining is the
most brutal competitive business in the
world
um and and you have to be a top tier uh
operation to survive multiple Cycles
China continues to be abrasive towards
Bitcoin or the reverse course realize
they made a mistake and come back
uh I'm not uh not a China expert but I I
uh you know communism and Bitcoin don't
mix um it's oil and water uh so I'd be
surprised if Xi Jinping you know open
arm embraced Bitcoin but you know who
knows
New York Nashville Miami Austin San
Francisco or LA
now Amanda San Fran uh been to La once
uh pretty bullish on Nashville bullish
on Miami bullish on New York uh you know
I guess I'll just go with Nashville
because that's where Beach sync is from
um but uh you know I got 11 no tax
jurisdictions too so Miami I'll give it
a runner up there tank top or Hawaiian
shirt both
for those that are only listening that's
what he's wearing uh would you rather
take the back or buy ethereum
uh I would load up on eth
all right where can we send people to
find you on the internet you can find me
on Twitter uh at Dylan Leclair
underscore Dylan leclair.com uh yeah
it's been a fun one all right I
appreciate it very much we'll definitely
do it again
cheers